what's behind the recent tension between
serbia and kosovo the two sides have met
in brussels to resolve a dispute sparked
by vehicle license plates but are they
likely to find an agreement and can
conflict be avoided this is inside story
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
muhammad jim joom the leaders of serbia
and kosovo have held rare talks in
brussels that european union mediators
hope will de-escalate growing tensions
the two sides have been at odds ever
since kosovo declared independence from
serbia in 2008.
nato says it's increasing its troop
numbers along the border with renewed
fears of a possible conflict in the
region the alliance's chief jens
stoltenberg has met separately with both
leaders and called for calm while saying
nato troops were ready to intervene if
necessary
the latest dispute was sparked last
month when kosovo said serbian identity
documents and car plate numbers would no
longer be valid in its territory the
serb minority in kosovo reacted angrily
to the restrictions on movement
prompting kosovo's government to delay
the measures until next month
we'll bring in our guests in a moment
first al jazeera's agnes zorich has more
from brussels
the first meeting of the highest
officials of serbia and kosovo after
more than a year is taking place at the
time of high enough tensions and
rhetoric that is so strange that the
european commission describes it as
inflammable european diplomats emphasize
that they are determined that the
meeting will continue until a solution
to the current crisis is found latest
engines were triggered late in july
ahead of course of intention to
implement a law making all citizens
including serbs to use kosovar car
plates also people from serbia entering
kosovo would have to have pristina
issued exit entry documents which would
be used as an id during they stay this
move triggered local serbs who put up a
roadblocks and sounded a raid sirens
police stated that even several gunshots
have been reported kosovo postponed the
implementation of the law for one month
and serbs have removed their roadblocks
but the tangents have stayed ahead of
september 1st which is a new date of
planned implementation nato secretary
general jens stoltenberg held meetings
with both president of serbia and kosovo
prime minister which was not an usual
practice ahead of eu facilitated
dialogue his message was loud and clear
nato peacekeeping mission in kosovo k
for his 4 000 troops and it's ready to
intervene if stability between serbia
and kosovo is at risk i call on all
sides to show restraint and to avoid
violence
nato continues to monitor close to the
situation on the ground
our k for peacekeeping mission remains
focused on its un mandate
should stability be jeopardized k for
stance ready to intervene
we do not agree on almost anything but
what's important is that serbia will
stick to international law and
agreements and everything that was
signed kosova's institutions and
citizens in the current situation have
reason to be vigilant
about destructive approach of our
northern neighbor towards kosovo and the
region in general under russia's
detrimental agenda for europe and the
balkans both votice and court said that
they are willing to work on the
escalation in order to find a mutually
agreeable solution for the normalization
of relations of serbia and its former
province that declared its independence
in 2008. in brussels for inside story
augmented
all right let's get a closer look at
this story kosovo declared its
independence from serbia in 2008 after
years of strained relations between the
majority ethnic albanian population and
minority serbs but it has not been
recognized by the u.n or serbia
while the u.s and some eu countries have
welcomed the move
and serbia has blocked kosovo from
joining various international
institutions but both are now seeking to
join the european union so normalizing
relations is seen as crucial for their
bids
all right let's bring in our guests in
prashina una haidari a reporter for
politico europe in sarajevo alexander
brezar a western balkans analyst host
and producer of the podcast calling
and in belgrade human rights lawyer
milan antonijevic
a warm welcome to you all and thanks so
much for joining us today on inside
story
let me start with you today from your
perspective can this meeting yield any
concrete results
what we've seen so far is that coastal
prime minister ibn korte has said that
he does not he's not withdrawing his
pledge to apply reciprocity measure
measures starting on september 1st
which means that
kosovo the coast of our side isn't going
to back down from insisting that serbian
citizens who enter kosovo um not be able
to travel with license plates that are
issued in serbia and that they need
special entry documents
um we're at this moment waiting like
precisely this moment waiting for the eu
to hold a conference that had a foreign
policy chief for the european union to
hold a press conference and give some
indication of what the agreement is in
brussels um but what i'm predicting at
this point is that they're going to try
to find an intermediate solution that'll
try to come over some of the differences
that exist between the two sides and in
order to like delay the the the
intensity or the tensions that we're
seeing right now
milan um serbian president alexander
vucic said that he expected difficult
talks with kosovo's prime minister uh he
said we do not agree almost on anything
so from your vantage point how difficult
do you think these talks are going to be
um well
i i believe that uh there is an urge to
to come to agreement especially on the
freedom of movement we saw what uh the
measures introduced by kosovo at the end
of july i mean on the august the first
uh produced and then they produced also
in security uh on the north of kosovo
knowing that and
knowing all the facts uh related to
security i believe that the serbian side
is ready and willing to negotiate they
showed it also in the past there were
some agreements uh not on the highest
level reached such as the agreement on
energy sector recently so i i believe
that there is potential that and that
serbia should insist
uh on already signed agreements that
serbia should also insist on the on the
future of the dialogue as as such and to
see how to overcome the difficulties
that exist
at the moment uh we saw albin kurtia i
think few months ago we had a very tough
discussion as a civil society and parts
of the society dealing with serbian and
kosovo relations
uh
but i expect that
in the in the name of the security of
the population on the whole apostle
the agreement especially on the freedom
of movement must be
on the horizon uh and that this is a
good start no matter how the
first positions are
far from each other
alexander from your perspective what
does brussels hope to achieve both in
the short term and in in the long term
yeah i think this is a really important
key question today especially um
you know the as both sides have said the
conversation or the dialogue has stalled
over the past year or so not if not
longer uh we've seen several
flare-ups um in in the meantime and
brussels has always attempted you know
as as whoever rather brussels has
attempted as always
to be the sort of mediating pacifying um
you know side to this um i honestly if
we're going to be perfectly honest about
this i don't expect much more than just
the usual kicking the can down the road
um brussels does not necessarily and you
know the officials in brussels don't not
necessarily have
um you know much of a carrot or much of
a stick to the care that they have
offered to both sides in this and i do
not expect some sort of a
grand solution to the to the outstanding
problems um
when it comes to this issue
or uh if you know any any anything
that's going to go beyond what we've
usually heard which is that both sides
have a very rigid stance on on the
problems that they're trying to resolve
oona of course there are many who are
worried right now that kosovo and serbia
might be headed toward another war you
wrote a piece for politico earlier this
month where you said that on the ground
in kosovo people have been downplaying
that possibility uh and the panic had
subsided at least for now so what is the
mood at the moment
well people in pristine are actually as
i said in that article and and many
others have um echoed people in pristine
are surprised that there's suddenly such
a big global interest in
uh the conflict between coastal and
serbia or the what when i say i guess we
should care be careful with the terms
that we use when i say conflict i mean
the intractable
uh tensions that exist between the two
countries but that are not armed by any
means at this point um
they're surprised that there's such an
interest in what's happening because
various forms of or similar forms of
violence intentions um have existed and
been recurring over the past couple of
years um i think uh everyone understands
that everyone in europe is on much
higher and a much higher level of alert
alertness and and and sort of anxiety
over this because of the ongoing
invasion of ukraine but
people don't understand why people are
that interested on the other hand i feel
like the ten the stakes are very high
right now because
um
primarily serbia is the country that's
being pushed in a corner it's being
expected to
make a final sort of
move with regard to sanctions towards
russia it's one of the few countries in
europe that is not participating in
sanctions packages against
the russian federation and everyone in
kosovo believes that because serbia is
being pressured by brussels to
participate in these sanctions that
could be more prone to radical moves
especially when it comes to kosovo
milan um i know you touched on this a
bit in your previous answer but you know
where do things go from here what
happens next what are the next steps
well i i fully disagree with this
statement that there is a can in this
and that is hit
down down the street i heard it before
also during the day during the
negotiations so i wouldn't simplify it
as as as such there are there is a large
question of insecurity especially on the
north that people feel and this is a
genuine feeling from from a serbian
community on the north there is also the
announcement that president witch will
talk with the serbian community today
uh calming it down and as uh
he did also uh at the beginning of
august when he had the first
uh
crisis if we may call it uh like that so
i wouldn't make any bigger parallel with
the
russian aggression to ukraine there is
no possibility that anything like it
happened in our region
um
as long as both parties are dedicated to
the dialogue alexander nato secretary
general jens stoltenberg has said that
the situation on the ground has improved
where do things stand right now
um
look um
there's something that has to be said
about this and
and it's related to what mr antonio said
before me um when it comes to kicking
the can down the road in brussels uh it
is important to note that all these
meetings have recently been all about
kicking the can down the road because
brussels has not offered anything to any
of the sides and i'm not just talking
about cosmo serbia i'm talking about all
of the western balkan states who are
attempting trying to be uh you know eu
members at some point down the road so
uh you know in terms of serbia that's
that's that's the from further
formalizing the accession process
they're moving it along for for costs of
it's just getting visa liberalization
which has been stocked for years et
cetera et cetera so um these meetings
between between uh pristine and belgrade
their convenient way for both sides and
and on both ends now you have you have
you know strong men especially
especially
in mr wuchu president of serbia um
but also in mr corti at the same time on
kosovo side where both sides are flexing
muscles and trying to to push the other
side into into some kind of a corner uh
where they will have to make a mistake
and it's all about this kind of
diplomatic uh slash political slash um
uh what do you want to call it to
arm wrestle that that's taking place in
front of our eyes uh but when it comes
to things on the ground and this is i
think this is important it is something
that mr antoniovic might not know
because i don't know what's the last
time he was in the north of kosovo i've
i've been there i've talked to people
it's my job to do that um
you know people's concerns might be
legitimate but people's concerns are not
being you know and when we were talking
about ethnic service in the north of
kosovo they might be legitimate in terms
of them feeling a particular way them
feeling maybe afraid or or scared or or
you know um
pushed into a corner again in a very in
a very um direct sense
but belgrade is not helping much either
and belgrade is not helping much either
by continuing this cat and mouse game
with christina without actually getting
to any kind of a solid result or any
kind of practical resolution to any of
the problems
regardless of the provocations from both
sides and that has to be taken into
account uh in terms of just the general
security situation i think that uh
it's it's worth noting that just uh 60
kilometers down the road uh in the
capital pristina you have concerts that
are taking place people are you know
going on with their lives as if uh you
know there's there's no crisis similar
thing in belgrade in the capital of
serbia um
and and people who have who have been
caught in the crosshairs here these very
epic serves that that mr antoniwicz is
talking about are the ones who are
legitimately concerned but i do not see
that you know their leaders though their
representatives are actually doing
anything to make their lives better and
this is not just about finding a
solution with christina this is this has
a lot to do with very practical things
on the ground where belgrade the claims
to be you know responsible for these
people um
basically does nothing and has done and
has done nothing for years except use
them as political pawns in this like i
said cast and mouse game between between
the two sets
uh in the event that that fighting were
to actually erupt uh if if tensions
escalate again um you know kosovo and
serbia are bound by an agreement in
which nato has the final say i want to
ask you just how entwined uh nato and
the eu are in the local peacekeeping
efforts
nato is absolutely
the final arbiter in any conflict or
escalation that could erupt between
kosovo and serbia um when the nato
bombing of
the rump state of yugoslavia happened or
serbia montenegro and obviously kosovo
ii happened in 1999
an agreement was signed that was
unprecedented that continues to be
unprecedented in nato history
which basically
means that any time serbia would want to
encroach the territory of kosovo
militarily or otherwise it would
immediately provoke a reaction from nato
so something that is that the public
might be more familiar with in terms of
the article 5 protections in nato um
exists when it comes to kosovo even
though kosovo is a nato member this is
why people on the ground have to some
extent downplayed the possibility of an
all-out war happening that doesn't mean
that there can't be incidents and peop
you know sadly tensions or even loss of
life but a full-out conflict in in
you know similar to anything that's
happening in ukraine is almost entirely
impossible precisely because uh nato's
forces on the ground in kosovo has spent
the last 20 years
um almost exclusively protecting the
northern border and making sure that
both the kosovo albanian and the coast
of australia community are protected in
those territories um
like i said again that doesn't mean that
there couldn't be incidents and stuff
like that but an actual
full-on conflict is almost entirely
unlikely milan in the aftermath of the
latest flare-up uh kosovo's interior
minister accused serbia and russia of
triggering and supporting rioting what
has the response to that been from
serbia
um well linking linking serbia to russia
fully is uh more uh uh of a fake dilemma
there is a serbian policy that's fully
independent from any uh russian
influence uh and the security of the
population of the serbs on north is uh
their uh their own stake and belgrade
does not play with that as far uh as i
can see i've been to kosovo just a month
ago i visited also that channel where
uh nato k4 forces are protecting the
monastery they're also working on in all
of the enclaves and they they're also
very agile in
avoiding any of the
provocation from either side but the
thing that i know speaking with the
serbian community on the north is that
the special forces of kosovo while
entering
the north there are always incidents
small incidents however
if the tensions are rising uh i believe
that these incidents can be
seen as a provocation and i hope that uh
especially because oversized and
pristina will not try to uh to uh
to to make any any uh reasons for the
serbian community that's frightened at
the moment uh to to react so um it's the
the the responsibility is shared i
believe that both sides that are now
meeting in brussels in front of the
community there uh and and all the envoy
and also
uh braille uh they they are aware of
these facts
uh and
everything that uh both serbia and
kosovo will get they will get it on the
negotiating table i believe that this
notion is uh well
um
placed in in belgrade i hope and i i
i uh the this is the message that we
transferred also to albin courty when we
spoke with him in june uh that the
negotiating table should be the only
table uh for uh solving any of the
issues there is no luckily there is no
zelansky in the region there is no putin
in the region either
so
there is there is no possibility for any
uh larger conflict to evolve and also
the recent thoughtenberg's messages
related to the security and the
employment of nato forces is also giving
a strong signal that
none of the possibilities for greater
conflict is not in on the western
balkans
and that everybody is aware just
following the situation and trying to
solve every issue that exists especially
issues related to freedom of movement
and any other freedom that should be
guaranteed to everyone on kosovo and
also i i i may put also a positive note
to
uh
serbia supporting the visa
liberalization of uh force for kosovo or
citizens related to the eu and this
these these are the gestures that should
be seen as as positive because
uh they will and they have to the the
the possibility to open many of the
purses that were
uh
on on uh still uh in in brussels uh
alexander the eu has said that both
serbia and kosovo need to normalize
their relations if they wish to
ultimately join the bloc
if the eu were to eventually accept
serbia and kosovo as member states is
that something that would diffuse these
tensions at all
that is that is a really good question
here's the thing for her for serbia to
enter uh the eu it has to recognize the
independence of kosovo um the the 35th
chapter of the current eu negotiations
deals with exactly that it is absolutely
clear it has become absolutely clear
over the years that the only way for
serbia to enter the eu and become a
full-fledged member state is to
recognize kosovo now what that
recognition actually uh will look like
in practice it's a different thing
obviously
there might be a little bit of room to
maneuver there but um
i don't know i do not see serbia
entering the eu without actually
resolving this in a way that's that's
that's positive for everyone uh not just
one side uh as far as kosovo is
concerned i think there are several
things at play uh when it comes to it's
it's eu membership bit uh as you know
it's it's
bundled together with bosnia and
herzegovina as a potential quote-unquote
potential um candidate country it's uh
what i like to call a cardboard medal uh
that was just given out to the two uh
two countries
uh because for you know
based on at least some uh on the opinion
of people in brussels or the officials
in brussels the two do not fulfill
certain requirements uh to be
full-fledged candidate countries like
montenegro serbia north macedonia and
albania um
on the other hand if you look at all the
you know all the actual uh
practicalities of what life is like in
kosovo what the politics are like what
the political life is like in kosovo uh
we are talking about the youngest
democracy in the world western style
democracy in the world we're talking
about the youngest country the most
recently uh
uh the most country that has most
recently declared independence and has
been partially recognized in europe uh
the second youngest in the world it's a
very vibrant society it's a very vibrant
uh environment
it's much more you could even say that
it's much more democratic than some
other candidate countries from the
region
and uh despite this
i mean the state or the position that it
has found itself in
is in my opinion very sad when it comes
to about two million people who live
there regardless of their ethnicity
um
alexander sorry i'm sorry to interrupt
but we're starting to run out of time we
only have about a minute and a half left
i also want to ask you um
if nato were to intervene or or step up
its presence even further
is that something that that would really
be a de-escalatory measure you know
would it ultimately help or or could
that actually inflame things as well
uh there are certain rules and
regulations that um you know determine
how much involvement nato can have both
in kosovo and as you know also in bosnia
herzegovina where it has a presence
through the e4 mission
um obviously something would have to
things would have to escalate between
kosovo and serbia first for nato to you
know intervene can it be more physically
present on the ground can can there be
more you know actual boots on the ground
that there were people
that's that's a really interesting
question and whether that would lead to
anything i don't think there's a need
for that at the moment i i personally
don't see it
um
and and i don't see that that would play
uh in into this whole thing as a sort of
a factor that would that would make
things worse i think nato's presence in
kosovo uh is is a positive thing and i
think it makes everyone feel much safer
both the ethnic albanian community the
ethnic serb community and all other
communities that live in kosovo all
right well we have run out of time so
we're going to have to leave the
conversation there today thanks so much
to all of our guests una haidari
alexander brazar and milan antonievic
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website aljazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story for me
muhammad zhum and the whole team here
bye for now
you